[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui hubert
védrine 14 ans auprès de françois
mitterrand président de la république
comme conseiller diplomatique d'abord
puis secrétaire général de l'elysée et
cinq ans au quai d'orsay en tant que
ministre des affaires étrangères du
gouvernement de lionel jospin sous la
présidence de jacques chirac
aujourd'hui vous publier un dictionnaire
amoureux de la géopolitique aux éditions
plon et fayard on peut donc aimé la
géopolitique
on a pourtant l'habitude de lui prêter
aucune vertu
ce sont essentiellement des rapports de
force et pourtant quand on voulait on
prend plaisir en effet à la géopolitique
alors en quoi est-elle aimable d'après
vous écoutez c'est un titre trompeur
mais c'est le titre magnifique d'une
collection qui a un grand succès depuis
longtemps dictionnaire amoureux
en fait c'est pas un vrai dictionnaire
pas de calais tas de sujets dont je ne
parle pas on ne parle que de ce que l'on
a envie de traiter en fait et j'ai
notamment parlé de du sujet où j'ai un
point de vue un peu différent du point
de vue dominant ou alors pour remettre
de la profondeur historique
ils peuvent être amoureux de la
géopolitique on paie de fasciner
passionnait impressionné tout ce qu'on
veut mais c'est le c'est le nom de la
collection
alors après j'ai ton de là je veux pas
parler dans l'histoire je vais formuler
ma question autrement
quel plaisir y prenez vous à vous y
intéressez à vous plonger là dedans à
être resté très actif sur ce sujet
encore aujourd'hui longtemps après avoir
été aux affaires ça continue de vous
fascine et pourquoi je ne sais pas je
suis fabriqué comme ça c'est m'a
toujours passionné même enfant enfant je
rêvais mais à partir plus tôt dès les
explorateurs ou des mémoires être avait
envoyé joseph kessel des choses comme ça
mais le monde les ils comprennent
travers des romans d'espionnage
donc le monde l'histoire la géographie
la façon dont ça s'entrechoquent les
grandes et si les grandes décisions et
grands décideurs avant même de connaître
le mode jeu politique
j'étais attiré par toutes ces choses et
puis j'ai vu des gens même très jeune
j'ai admiré des personnages et puis y
est j'ai la chance d'avoir été entraîné
dans l'épopée mitterrand bon donc puis
j'ai vu les grands dirigeants
encore une fois c'est
ma nature c'est ma forme d'esprit je
peux pas le théorisé et ça évidemment
continuer à me passionner même après les
19 années où j'étais au coeur du pouvoir
elle s'arrête très intéressant mais avec
une dimension historique parce que tout
quand même effarant la société moderne
qui ont le nez sur le guidon on comprend
absolument rien aux comportements des
chinois des russes des iraniens des
israéliens qui on veut si on n'a pas en
tête un peu de profondeur historique
mais c'est pas un traité rasoir énorme
la vue twingo par rapport à ça il ya des
dictionnaires amoureux beaucoup beaucoup
plus épais que celui ci pour vous
d'ailleurs ça commence par le mot
acteurs pour vous les états restent les
acteurs principaux des relations
internationales même si d'autres acteurs
existent aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi pourquoi est ce que c'est
que ce sont toujours les états qu'on a
longtemps en tout cas pendant un certain
temps pensé totalement obsolète
ça c'était en occident c'était en tout
cas en europe occidentale et les
européens ont une vision angélique des
choses depuis quelques décennies
il ya d'ailleurs un un grand ministre
allemand maintenant président qu'il y a
attention nous les européens nous sommes
des herbivores géopolitique dans un
monde de carnivores géopolitique et dans
le reste du monde persona jamais cru à
la disparition des états dans la vraie
différence par rapport à l'époque on va
dire de richelieu c'est que les états ne
sont plus seuls
donc c'est pas les souverains les
dirigeants les rois qui ont le monopole
des relations internationales ias il ya
un grouillement d'autres acteurs mais à
la fin tout le monde les connaît dans la
société d'aujourd'hui et à la fin des
fins quand il faut décider quelque chose
quand il faut s'engager
que ce soit sur le climat ou sur des
questions de sécurité il faut bien des
entités qui signent et qui peut faire
respecter les engagements et bas ce sont
les états sont toujours là il n'avait
jamais disparu
ils sont toujours là mais pas seul c'est
donc toujours une question de numéros de
téléphone ce que disait henry kissinger
à propos de l'europe l'europe quel
numéro de téléphone la france
l'allemagne on sait qui appeler le repos
fait pas oui mais c'était une remarque
ironique pas entièrement fausse du
kiss-in gueule parce qu'ils voulaient
pas être embêté dans les négociations
par une espèce d'entité européenne une
sorte d'hybride qui à son époque
d'ailleurs pesé beaucoup moins
qu'aujourd'hui il n'aurait pas fait
cette remarque sur sur la france
il aurait très bien su que c'était le
numéro de téléphone de l'elysée et qu'il
fallait faire donc c'est une remarque
sur l'europe parce que keith singer
globalement il a toujours évidemment
surtout lui il a défendu le rôle in fine
et des états même quand il ya des
entreprises quand il ya les médias quand
il ya des organisations sportives les
religions et compagnie à la fin des fins
les états restent ce qu'ils n'ont pas
cessé d'être
donc c'est c'est les gentils européens
de l'ouest un peu bisounours soyez qui
doivent arrêter rire dans le monde réel
même s'il est plus décevant que ce
qu'ils avaient rêvé et et la communauté
internationale dieu sait si on en parle
souvent est ce qu'elle est dans le monde
réel
non il n'ya pas de communauté leveaux
copie notée est un terme chaleureux une
communauté faut qu'ils aient des liens
qu'ils soient reconnus comme tels qui
créent des solidarités et c'est donc et
des tas de communauté et dans mes
membres dans le monde dans chaque pays
le monde ne forme pas une communauté
c'est une foire d'empoigné est une foire
d'empoigné
rappelez-vous d'ailleurs à la fin de
l'union soviétique les occidentaux on
pensait avoir gagné voilà la théorie de
la fin de l'histoire on a gagné la
démocratie le marché s'impose partout et
en réalité l'histoire s'était remise en
marche
c'est exactement l'inversé et on peut
pas dire que les chinois même les
chinois voyant et qu'ils soient pas un
dirigeant ou les briques mais ils n'ont
pas la même vision du monde les peuples
n'ont pas peur des mêmes choses ils ont
pas les mêmes espérances
ils ont évidemment des intérêts vitaux
commun et peut-être que cette sentiment
de d'appartenance et une vraie
communauté en général va venir avec le
développement de la prise de conscience
sur les dangers écologiques et la
nécessité de l'écologisation peut-être
mais dans le monde d'aujourd'hui 2022 en
est pas là donc c'est un objectif que la
communauté est un bel objectif
mais c'est pas la réalité d'aujourd'hui
alors si on prend la france maintenant
on pourrait se dire que veut la france
on parle toujours de géopolitique bien
sûr mais vous montrez bien aussi qu' il
ya un avant et un après jacques chirac
par exemple hier il y aurait eu une
volonté de la france qui va jusqu'à
jacques chirac qui reste dans ce une
idée golo mitterrandiste on va dire et
puis après jacques chirac ça commence
avec nicolas sarkozy sa part ailleurs
est ce que est ce que d'abord c'est est
ce que c'est juste est ce que c'est vrai
est-ce que c'est comme ça que ça se
passe
et à ce moment là
le que veut la france est ce que c'est
si estoril que ça je voudrais rappeler
que mon livre n'est pas sur la france en
particulier un il ya 249 entre et
peut-être une dizaine qui concerne la
france mais c'est pas si on la france
mais c'est une évaluation de la
politique étrangère française ni de la
vème république
mais évidemment je parle aussi de la
france parce que la france est quand
même un acteur qui reste plus important
que ce que croient les français quand
ils sont déprimés
sans tomber pour autant dans la
grandiloquence qui n'est pas qui est
disproportionné
donc oui ils ont il ya une histoire de
la vème république qui va de de gaulle
jusqu'à mitterrand gaulle au
mitterrandisme et jacques chirac en tout
cas le septennat
parce que je pense qu'une part des
éléments de la césure c'est le
quinquennat en fait c'est le fait que le
président le chef de l'état n'a pas un
horizon politique assurée au delà du
parlement qui est là donc un élément qui
a déstabilisé à mon avenir il y avait
beaucoup de partisans du quinquennat
sinon oui ce périple a été mise en place
dès ya donc un élément qui affaiblit
relativement mais c'est un élément parmi
d'autres
globalement c'est beaucoup moins
important que le fait de noter que les
occidentaux qui ont eu le monopole de la
puissance et de l' influence et donc de
l'histoire avec un grand h
pendant trois quatre siècles ils ont
perdu ce monopole
ils n'ont pas perdu la puissance et
l'influencé qu'ils ont perdu ce monopole
donc les euros bien aussi donc la france
aussi nous il ya donc nuls une évolution
générale et la france et l'essai de
depuis la fin du système est ouest offre
les prises dans français successifs
essai de réadapter sans arrêt à la
politique étrangère de la france dans ce
monde global
c'est pas évident c'est très compliqué
il ya moins de levier et puis le monde
est mouvant le fuyant voyez bien tous
les phénomènes actuels mais un pays
comme l'allemagne par exemple qui est
sur le plan militaire n'a plus
d'importance mais qui sur le plan
économique est une grande puissance
est-ce qu'il peut avoir de l'influencé
en géopolitique
oui bien sûr parce que l'info commence
mesure l'influencent où il avait les
éléments classiques vous avez là la
force militaire conventionnelle ou
nucléaire
pour ceux qu'ils l'ont vous avez là la
capacité de se projeter vous avez là la
puissance de la monnaie du commerce et
cédera dans la puissance est un élément
combiné en fait quelque chose d'assez
immatériel et qui est l'idée que les
autres seront de votre puissance
c'est là où le soft power peut être
considérable il ya des puissances qui
ont pas tellement de ce poids il ya des
puissances qui est un support plus grand
que leur pouvoir réel bon voilà tout ça
ça donne un système un peu enviable
hi-fi côté où tout le monde se tient un
peu comme ça par la barbichette et après
faut évaluer au cas par cas selon les
moments
mais les européens globalement la vous
parle de l'allemagne on peut se poser la
question sur l'allemagne puis à prix
madame merkel par exemple bon et
l'allemagne a une puissance et économie
qui qui se voit dans le fait que le les
grandes décisions récentes comme par
exemple la l'abandon des critères de 3%
vous savez sur le déficit
la conception du plan de relance
n'aurait pas existé si l'allemagne avait
pas bougé en fait si l'allemagne avait
pas accepté donc on voit le poids le
poids qui est issu de la de la
réunification qui d'autre part des
réformes de schröder en allemagne bon
mais c'est dans un ensemble qui dans la
puissance est même relativement
stagnante ses solides l'europe puisque
la projection qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui c'est que pendant 10 ans 20
ans c'est la rivalité qui peut devenir
lui rhin entre les etats-unis et la
chine qui commande l'ensemble c'est pas
en allemagne où la france c'est autre
chose
alors est ce que les européens sont
évidemment collectivement les européens
pèsent plus s'ils sont unis mais aucun
peuple européen ne soutient la
conception classique de la construction
en europe et east dans lesquelles la
souveraineté leur échappe de plus en
plus longues et une combinaison a trouvé
une vieille formule de delors qui était
très réaliste en fait fédération d'états
nations et aujourd'hui les les
gouvernements les élites les dirigeants
en europe sont pas trouvé encore là ils
ont paré qu'on ne sont pas réconciliés
avec les peuples donc ça ça ça a des
conséquences sur la façon dont l'europe
lepez ou ne pèse pas va peser ou non
dans la suite de l'aventuré tel génie
chine
on en reviendra aux états unis à la
chine mais l'otan dit que c'est la seule
alliance militaire encore existantes et
en même temps vous dites aussi dans
votre livre que l'europe et les états
unis ne
son sont destinés d'après vous à
s'éloigner les uns des autres
oui parce que je ré introduit beaucoup
d'histoires dans le livre comme ça c'est
pas un traité des crises c'est pas un
traité des relations tant de saint denis
de la diplomatie mme d'aujourd'hui c'est
une promenade historique agents jyske
ans et alexandre le grand angle et à la
bataille de cadets iliad a poleo il ya
plein de choses comme ça
bon alors dans la longue distance en
réalité les états unis et l'europe
étaient issus d'un d'une histoire
commune
mais il s'éloignait gentiment il suffit
de voir le 20e siècle
en fait ils sont ils ont énormément
tardé à intervenir dans la guerre 14 18
parce que l'opinion américaine étaient
partagés moitié moitié
ils sont intervenus en 17 est ce que les
allemands en ont le tort de l'époque ont
eu le temps de couler les bateaux
américains
ils sont arrivés en 17 ils sont pas
restés après il ya à nouveau dans les
années vingt et trente et une grille qui
est assez distancié au fait et même si
roosevelt pense que c'est l'intérêt des
états unis de rentrer dans la guerre et
de pas laissées de churchill seul il
faut attendre d' attaque de pearl harbor
par les japonais pour qu'il rentre donc
d'ailleurs madeleine albright eux disent
souvent comme nous avions des polémiques
amical est très mignon n'a pas cherché
gouverner le monde
on est venus à cause d' hitler et on est
resté à cause de staline ce qui se passe
après étant donné qu'il n'ya plus de
menace assez mama tu es à moi est donnée
qui a plus de menace spécialement
dirigée sur états unis et europe ce qui
était le cas avec lurs de staline
ce qui a créé l'alliance atlantique de
façon défensive il ya plus ça il ya des
tas de menaces dans le monde actuel ne
sont pas spécifiques
voilà elle concerne tout le monde le
compte à rebours écologique loyer donc
je pense pas que le cet élément qui a
créé cette relation transatlantique très
original très très génique en fait dans
l'histoire des peuples développer je
pense pas que ça va rester aussi fort
donc je pense que dans un avenir plus ou
moins lointain les deux entités vont se
distancier comme des cousins issu de
germain et même l'histoire des valeurs
communes n'est pas entièrement
convaincante quand on regarde les
chakras les américains et les européens
que ça mais dans la conjoncture
immédiate
et là je reviens à l'actualité sous la
présidence ben haydn et une volonté très
claire pour les états unis de revenir
dans le multilatéralisme là les
européens applaudissent mais pour
revenir pour exercer le leadership
américain
donc pour avoir une entité organisé pour
dissuader la russie et endiguer la chine
alors il ya des européens qui auraient
trouvé ça génial et des européens qui
vont être embarrassé qui rêvent d'un
disons d'une politique européenne nous y
aller tout ce qu'on veut mais qui est
quand même un peu d'autonomie
c'est une question qui est devant nous
mais en profondeur je crois que les
sociétés sont amenées à diverger
doucement lentement
le président américain est encore
appelée surtout aux états unis
d'ailleurs jusqu'en europe
on l'appelle encore le chef du monde
libre ça peut paraître anachronique
c'est un slogan anachronique oui il ya
eu chez les américains depuis la guerre
après 45 est assez nettement après la
fin de lurs idée de rassembler tout le
monde qui n'est pas l'ours ou la chine
c'est plus ou moins fort selon les
moments mais il ya des périodes où les
états unis mènent des politiques très
réaliste très classique on va dire mais
pas tout le temps donc là nouveau on
nous parle de diplomatie des les valeurs
ce qui peut conduire à amener des
croisades voyait pour donc l'expression
mon libre qui correspond pas à la
situation d'aujourd'hui n'était pas
perçu qui n'est pas c'est très décalées
comme expression mais il ya quand même
du côté américain il c'est de rassembler
tout l'occident alors tout l'ouest et
ouest contre les autres contre brest le
west contre brest ou alors les
démocraties contre les autres le
problème étant de savoir comment on fait
la liste exacte des démocraties
il semblerait que pour le moment
l'administration byden blinken veulent
camper sa bon on verra ce que ça donne
mais c'est pas du tout du tout la proche
qui avait prévalu en france en tout cas
depuis de gaulle
c'est complètement différent alors on
sera peut-être assez malin pour se
débrouiller
on va voir
et le monde arabe moi j'ai toujours eu
l'impression que quand on parle du monde
arabe
c'est une c'est une façon en fait de le
j'allais dire de le rabaisser ce serait
méchant c'est pas ça mais mais d'en
faire quelque chose qui n'est pas
dangereux non c'est pas une création de
rapports à baisser mais il avait cédé
concept globaux qui sont pas très
opérante comme candide la dgi l'asie
sera le moteur du monde mais c'est qu'il
a dit est ce que c'est la chine ou
l'inde le japon bon quand on dit
l'afrique en général et c'est pas
tellement mieux
et quand même d afrique très différentes
bon le monde arabe c'est vrai qu'un
monde arabe
il ya un monde arabe qui est pas de
monde musulman est une partie du monde
musulman
ça dépend comment on en parle et si on
veut faire une analyse géopolitique le
terme endarra et attraits opérant parce
qu'en fait les il ya beaucoup de
différences voire de divergences entre
les grands pays arabes ne serait-ce que
au sein du maghreb par exemple
donc c'est une expression va dire quoi
culturel culturel politique historique
ça correspond aux pays qui ont été aux
yeux de binet conquis par les arabes
après au moment de l'expansion
phénoménalement rapide de l'islam par
des arbres venus d'arabie qui ont trouvé
des plus ou moins drôles et dans les
différentes populations y compris les
berbères du maroc
bon mais faut pas faut pas chercher à
mal sur cette expression ça dépend de la
façon dont les employés le contexte la
relation entre la chine et la russie
aujourd'hui si on remonte le passé on se
dit ça n'a jamais marché entre la chine
et la russie
il ya eu des moments d'alliances mais si
on remonte très haut vous avez toute la
colonisation russe
si au monde prévoit la commission russe
qui s'étend à l'est qui s'étend au sud
est est là elle rencontre pas la chine
parce que la chine s'étendent et phase
plutôt deux
disons de difficultés de division de
déclin des dynasties donc revanche l
époque contemporaine
même quand le la russie devient lurs urs
communistes ils sont rassemblées par une
alliance contre les états unis
donc il ya un long moment d'alliance
politique mais qui est artificiel on
voit bien puisque coeur ça finit par se
briser et c'est à dire là dessus que
keith singer jouera sa carte pour faire
de la chine pendant un temps assez long
une sorte de vrais alliés des etats-unis
et pour empêcher que les la chine et la
russie se rapprochent puis après ça
repart dans l'autre sens dans les vingt
dernières jamais vous savez il ya eu
avec la le développement accéléré de la
mondialisation surtout depuis que dan
shopping à libérer les énergies de la
chine on avait créé mes cd zig des
économistes de banque qui disait ça on
écrit l'acronyme brics brésil russie
inde chine
et il avait ajouté après afrique du sud
south africa
bon ça n'a pas de vrai sens géopolitique
sauf la question il en russie chine et
l'inde away squid and là dedans mais
c'est pas une unité puisque les
américains dans la phase actuelle 1 ils
veulent mettre en place une stratégie
indo pacifique pour endiguer la chine
c'est à dire avec l'inde et peut-être
qu'ils mettront ça en avant dans le
chemin des démocraties s'il arrive à
faire la liste des pays qui sont
démocratiques en tout cas à leurs yeux
donc c'est un jeu vous avez raison qui
reste ouvert et on peut pas du tout
raisonner comme s'il y avait eu une
alliance constante et c'est pas non plus
le conflit constant il faut ajouter à ça
qu'il ya quand même une inquiétude du
côté russe par rapport à d'immensité
désertique de la sibérie il ya environ
une vingtaine de millions d'habitants
entre l'oral et le pacifique une ville
de 20 millions d'habitants en chine vous
connaissez même pas le don qu'il m'a pas
c'est parce qu il l ordi et l'inquiétude
était assez nette d'ailleurs dans l'est
dans les mémoires très intéressante d'un
à mes anciens collègues russes qui était
devenu premier evgueni primakov
heikki expliquer cette inquiétude là des
russes alors il faut asseoir une
alliance tout à fait solide avec la
chine et que la chine va amener à
respecter de l'alliance ou alors il
faudrait à la fois développer peuple et
toute la sibérie c'est des enjeux très
très compliqué mais il peut y avoir je
crois que vous gardez les deux
hypothèses de l'alliance ce guide ou de
l'affrontement entre les deux entités
il y aura des hauts et des bas il y aura
des mésententes tactiques et des
ententes tactique entre les deux ça
dépend aussi de ce qu'on fait nous ça
dépend si l'occident un jeu simple et
binaire qui amène l'ensemble des autres
à se regrouper ou si l'occident est plus
malin et l'inde alors puisque vous en
parlez on a l'impression de ces
dernières années je crois que vous
employer cette expression d'hindouisme
agressif quelque chose de totalement
nouveau
en tout cas ça semble totalement nouveau
est-ce que ça l'est quand on regarde
justement sur le long terme
bon c'est pas entièrement nouveau
historiquement mais en tout cas c'est
complètement différent de ce qui a été
de l'inde après le départ des
britanniques dans des conditions
épouvantables après la partition avec
des quantités de mort astronomique entre
les deux moments la séparation entre
l'inde et le pakistan occidental
oriental puisqu'il devient donc pectine
orientale qui devient le bangladesh et
des moments de violence rappelez-vous
que yeux que gandhi et ss et signer par
un nationaliste hindou par exemple même
gandhi à cause de la non violence
et puis il ya eu quand même beaucoup d'
assassinats politiques en inde même dans
la longue période
nehru gandhi ni gandhi qui est pas la
même famille que le gandhi pour roux et
donc c'était sous jacent c'était de
l'art mais ça se voyait pas puis nous
les occidentaux ne voulait voir que
c'est un de modernistes progressistes
les figures de nehru qui était
exceptionnellement intéressant et
tournée vers l'extérieur ouvert non il
est pas que ça en fait
donc il peut être un d'erreurs dans le
regard occidental sur l'inde
c'est pas dans les mêmes proportions
mais un peu la même erreur que quand on
regarde l iran du sadi renvoyé
les liront des chiites qui rend des
volailles qui bouillonnait par dessous
c'est pas tout à fait pareil les
conséquences sont moins extrêmes mais il
ya quand même une hindoue east qui est
là et qui revenue avec le premier
ministre actuel avec des tensions
énormes entre les hindouistes et les
musulmans mais ce qui me frappe encore
une fois ces pages je mets pas ma
famille dans le livre de longs
développements un peu rasoir sur chaque
pays mais c'est pour mettre l'accent sur
les éléments clés de l'incertitude
actuelle et de et de demain et ce qui me
frappe à propos de l'inde sait que c'est
un pays qui sait à sa façon très bien
inséré dans la mondialisation
tout le monde sait que la force
incroyable des ingénieurs des savants
indien et puis la puissance de
l'industrie à bangalore le développement
de bombay et en même temps ces
pellicules est en fait et c'est un pays
qui n'a pas été affecté en profondeur
par la mondialisation s'impliquer
beaucoup moins décérébrés à bienne et on
aurait dit à l'époque marxiste que
l'europe par exemple qui sait vraiment
plus bien qu'ils allaient en fait dans
tout ça après des décennies de
d'américanisation dont il ya un côté ya
en une qui fait penser avec une certain
fanatisme en plus au japon le japon qui
est ouvert est en fait un pénétrable et
qui restait profondément lui-même donc
fallu rechercher les racines de tout ça
quand on veut comprendre ce qui se passe
en ce moment et la suite d'où les
allers-retours historique il ya deux
livres qui ont marqué la géopolitique et
tout ce qui s'y intéressaient à la fin
du xxème siècle
c'est d'abord l'article puis le livre de
futurama sur la fin de l'histoire
et ensuite le choc des civilisations
juste un mot parce qu'on va faire une
pause dans une minute fut que yamaha est
ce que on ya cru un moment à la fin de
l'histoire
oui bien sûr mais je retiens croyez à ça
avant fukuyama
il était fou couilles avesque le côté
bisounours les européens y croyez à ça
bien avant
et quand fukuyama a dit ça aujourd'hui
mais oui bien sûr c'est ça que nous
aimons c'est ça que nous voulons
alors peut-être que ça sera vrai un jour
mais c'est pas vrai encore une
tiquetonne en fait avait moins tort que
fukuyama
il faut d'ailleurs rappeler que von
thing tonnes n'a jamais préconisé le
clash est assez effrayant il y attention
ne sommes pas dans une évolution à l'eau
de rose quoi il peut y avoir des clash
entre civilisations les yeux plein de
critiques dont certaines étaient fondées
mais je crains que pointant encore assez
long il n'est plus tôt plus raison que
que fukuyama ont fait une pause et on y
revient tout de suite du bébé
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours et qu'hubert
védrine qui publie un passionnant
dictionnaire amoureux de la géopolitique
aux éditions plon et fayard hubert
védrine n'y a pas eu de guerre déclaré
il n'y a pas eu d'affrontement militaire
entre les états unis et l'urss alors que
tout peut a priori s'y prêtait on a dit
que c'était grâce à leur rational
nucléaire qu'on avait trouvé un vaccin
contre contre la guerre au fond est ce
que ça veut dire qu'il n'y en aura pas
non plus entre les etats-unis et la
chine aujourd'hui
bon moi j'ai fait partie de ceux qui
considèrent qu'en effet pas simplement
l'arsenal la dissuasion nucléaire a
garanti la paix en tout cas entre les
grandes puissances nucléaires
par ailleurs même si contrairement à
l'impression qu'on a le nombre des
conflits et leurs conséquences a plutôt
tendance à diminuer la 17e journée
claire et simple c'est que on menace ses
adversaires potentiels de représailles
tellement épouvantable qui n'attaque pas
en fait donc une façon de garantir la
paix je pense que ça a joué
alors c'est discuter ce point parce que
là les antinucléaires disent qu'on peut
pas le prouver mais peuvent pas prouver
l'inversé et c'est bon entre les états
unis et la chine
bien sûr il ya les arsenal nucléaire
mais moi je ne pense pas qu'on puisse
écarter aujourd'hui
l'hypothèse d'un affrontement peut être
sans doute bref sans doute localisée
mais ce serait bien d'optimiste de dire
qu' il se passera rien autour de taiwan
dans les dix années qui viennent on
riait ou dans les mers de chine
donc nous excluent pas complètement qu'à
un moment donné un avion tire sur un
autre qu'un bateau soit écoulé quelque
chose alors les chinois que savent les
américains de sabre s'il y avait en
chine
des gens qui se disent que compte tenu
de l'état de l'occident les convulsions
internes sociales politiques
idéologiques la certain déclin
économique 19 à toute une série
d'éléments négatifs plus une amérique
copé en 2 politiquement et des élections
en permanence en occident siens un parti
en chine qui se dit c'est le moment d'en
profiter pour repousser les pions
du coup de tête taiwan là ce serait
vraiment dangereux vraiment dangereux
parce que pour les états unis accepté là
que pékin recontrôle par la force ou par
l'intimidation taïwan ça voudrait dire
que la garantie américaine ne voudrait
plus rien ne lui par nulle part dans le
monde et donc les ya un facteur de
désagrégation potentiel gigantesque très
dangereux mais en même temps ce que je
vais me dire tous les stratèges
américains ne savent également chinois
donc on peut imaginer qu'en amont même
si il y à des rodomontades des positions
des affirmations tout ça le jeu sera
verrouillée peut-être mais je pense pas
qu'on puisse affirmer qu' il n'y aura
pas quelque chose bien mais là il ya peu
de il a peu d'endroits au moins il ya de
l'autre endroit il pourrait y avoir un
quelque chose à conséquences mondiales
ses siens des islamistes virulent prenez
le contrôle du pakistan et de l'armé
nucléaire pakistanaise il ya deux trois
endroits comme ça où on peut se poser
des questions mais peut-être qu'il se
passera rien vu oui parce que je veux un
prophète de malheur
pendant la guerre froide j'aurais trouvé
personne pour me dire vous inquiétez pas
il ne se passera rien à ce que la
dissuasion nucléaire fait qu'il ne peut
rien se passer et on disait regardez
berlin il suffirait de très peu de
choses pour que yann et à celle et
toutes les puces en base et on était
tous d'accord là dessus
et pourtant il ne s'est rien passé et et
rétrospectivement on se dit bah oui il
ne pouvait rien se passer et je me
demande si on ne pourrait pas se dire la
même chose aujourd'hui
même si évidemment personne n'en prendra
le risque il ne peut rien se passer
entre la chine et les états unis parce
que ce serait trop grave et bien dans la
guerre froide
d'abord elle est restée froide comme
vous l'avez dit elle n'est pas devenue
chaude
c'est toute la différence hoyé trop la
guerre froide et la guerre chaude bon et
le blocus du mur de berlin
staline a raté son coucours envoyée bon
donc on peut réserver comprend dix ans
ce sera pareil mais en ce qui concerne
les états unis et lurs il était arrivé
un très haut degré quand même très haut
degré de menaces mutuelles donc de
dissuasion il y avait aucune marge
alors il ya eu des conflits
intermédiaire mais dans ce qu'on
appelait le troisième mandat tiers-monde
de l'époque
il ya plus de tirs monde aujourd'hui il
ya toute une collection de pays plus ou
moins émergents donc c'est moins
maintien c'est moi essai - cristalliser
à mon avis dans une posture de
dissuasion qui vient revue toutes les
hypothèses et on verra mais le juste je
serais très content que votre
comparaison soit exact c'est à dire que
la situation est verrouillée en termes
de paix un même entre la chine et les
états unis
ce qui n'empêchera pas la chine de
pousser ses pions de mille façons et
admettons votre hypothèse très bien
d'ailleurs mon livre n'est pas n'est pas
alarmiste 1 n'est pas kadhafi d'où il
est même souvent malicieux
allons plus loin les états ne se font
plus la guerre et les guerres entre
états ont été remplacés par des guerres
civiles ou des guerres de souveraineté
pourquoi oui mais ça c'est un
raisonnement des des européens sauf
c'est pas tellement les états c'est que
les états n'ont plus tellement
d'autonomie par rapport aux sociétés les
politiques étrangères sont souvent
dictées par le pignon ce qui peut amener
à changer tout le temps des reins et est
donc c'est des sociétés incapables
d'assumer la guerre en fait le mal
qu'ont les sociétés européennes
hédoniste individualiste et etc h une
médée des situations compliquées comme
la pandémie qui n'a rien à voir avec les
guerres mondiales
ça n'a rien à voir donc on voit bien
qu'il ya une sensibilité de fragilité on
imagine passé c'est ceci était en guerre
en fait mais enfin leurs emplettes
malheureusement que toutes les sociétés
ne sont pas comme ça il faut vraiment
tout faire pour que l'europe telle
qu'elle est devenue ne soient pas
confrontées à des menaces physiques vrai
déjà il ya liste il ya le terrorisme
islamique et les européens tergiversent
enfin sur la façon de désigner de dôme
est de traiter de prévenir etc etc
donc ça enfin beaucoup de choses dans
vos questions ramène à aux
interrogations sur l'europe
plus que sur les autres sur les
européens si les européens veulent
vraiment si vous regardez bien il n'y a
pas qu'en europe qui a plus de guerre
entre états les guerres interétatiques
c'est fini on pourrait dire vous avez
vécu ça d'ailleurs en première ligne
hubert védrine le dernier qui a essayé
c'est saddam hussein avec il ya eu la
guerre irak iran qui pour nous nous
semblait quelque chose d'un autre âge on
a l'impression de revoir la guerre de 14
ensuite il a envahi le koweït on n'avait
pas vu ça depuis une éternité on l'a
plus vu depuis d'ailleurs un état qui
pensent qu'il peut envahir l'autre et
elles annexée par exemple et puis à la
fin ça c'était avant
il s'arrête l'amérique envahissant
l'irak donc alors évidemment c'était pas
vécu comme une une guerre interethnique
mais enfin pourtant c'était quand même
ça mais au fond c'est la dernière fois à
travers saddam hussein qu'on a vécu des
guerres interétatiques
oui mais c'est pas tellement vieux non
c'est vrai vous parler d'événement qui
ont 20 à 30 ans et au yémen alors c'est
pas officiellement un terreau étatique
mais en fait au yémen l'arabie et l'iran
se combattent et par yéménite interposés
et sur le terrain et mais dites donc
vous allez un peu vite en besogne
est-ce que ça n'est pas pour ça
justement que parce qu'il n'y a plus de
dire été un terreau étatique mais des
guerres de souveraineté des guerres
civiles dans lequel d'autres puissances
bien entendu interviennent comme c'est
le cas au yémen est-ce que ça n'est pas
pour ça que les guerres sont finalement
moins brutale - et qu'elles font moins
de victimes qu'autrefois
non il ya un autre élément c'est que les
guerres ont fait des dégâts monstrueux
et des victimes immense colle les
systèmes militaires se sont
industrialisés ont acquis des capacités
de tueries de masse en quelque sorte et
on était encore à l'époque des combats
terrestres et d'immenses d'armes est et
reste la france
parme et française était la première du
monde en nombre en 1918 voyait par
rapport à ça donc il ya un moment qui a
coïncidé avec les épouvantables xxème
siècle sur se prend ce plan de guerre
etc des massacres monumentaux et on sait
les les millions et des millions de
morts provoquées par hitler par staline
par mao aussi pour d'autres raisons
on a l'impression que en effet c'est
derrière nous parce que même si la
compétition est là les anges de
puissance la volonté de domination
la chine va être numéro 1 les états unis
veulent pas que ce numéro on a
l'impression que même s'il y avait des
dés et à déterminer qui redevenait
fanatiques il n'aurait même pas besoin
de faire ça c'est c'est l'élément le
plus solide de votre question en fait il
aurait pas besoin de passer par ces
scénarios épouvantable de massacres de
masse parce que c'est sur d'autres
terrains qui sont économiques
technologiques financiers
les influences le fait que tout le monde
essaie de dans les sociétés où le pignon
est fort tout le monde essaie de
manipuler le pays d'en face en utilisant
des diasporas qui peuvent devenir des
lobbys ou des dés le des systèmes de
sanctions comme le dock il ya énormément
d'autres moyens que les tuyaux lillooet
bon ça paraît c'est une façon étrange
d'être optimiste mais c'est peut-être
deux une façon de ne pas projeter sur la
suite ce qui a été le 20e siècle
justement vous même mais prononcé le mot
sanction est ce que ça fonctionne les
sanctions les embargos
est ce que ça fonctionne sur le plan
interne ça fonctionne très bien parce
que les pays qui sanctionne en général
c'est pas tellement pour obtenir un
objectif rationnel c'est parce qu'il
faut calmer une partie de la population
prenez les etats-unis qui sont devenus
les champions du monde
les sanctions elles peuvent évidemment
ce qui se dit ici longue
ils ont voté eux mêmes des lois qui leur
donne le droit d'intervenir contre toute
entité qui utilise le dollar à un moment
donné
et comme le monde entier l'économie
mondiale est mondialisée ce qui est pas
mal financiarisé trop dérégulé beaucoup
trop de la risée ses troupes américains
etc etc
ils peuvent intervenir sur n'importe qui
sous prétexte de lutte contre le
terrorisme la corruption mais souvent en
réalité en fait en même temps pour
assurer leur intérêt est écarté des
concurrents donc aux états unis est une
machine infernale dont les etats-unis
les européens n'ont pas assez pris
conscience est d'ailleurs la commission
devrait se doter à mon avis le système
symétrique au moins pour dissuader et
pour discuter ou des sénateurs sont
actionnées par des lobbys très précis
aux états unis
mettre en marche des yeux des nouvelles
sanctions et comme il ya énormément de
mouvement les polonais des états unis où
les soucis cela les ukrainiens les
biélorusses et il ya des gars quasiment
des lobbys de tous les peuples du monde
sauf les français pour des raisons de
l'individualisme et de manque
d'organisation bref il ya des lobbys
partout qu'ils sont capables de
déclencher des sanctions américaines
le résultat c'est quasiment secondaire
en fait parce qu'il s'en fiche un peu
puisqu'ils peuvent après dire voyez j'ai
montré ma ferme était extraordinaire
face à la russie face à d'autres choses
je ne dis pas que le comportement russe
ou chinois autre est exemplaire c'est
pas le sujet allez je parle de la
mécanique interne donc et sanctions
répondent assez bien alors à leur
objectif qui est d'ordre de politique
intérieure mais je trouve ça nul 1-1
s'annulent lamentable ça n'a aucun
rapport avec une politique étrangère
vrai il ya quelques cas quand même
quelques cas il faut pouvoir se servir
de sanctions à condition qu'elle soit
intelligente et ciblées pour atteindre
un objectif de politique internationale
mais c'est assez rare parce qu'en
général elles sont contournées ça
déplace les équilibres dans les rapports
de force est malheureusement souvent ce
sont les peuples qui les subissent donc
je moi globalement je pense qu'il faut
il y avoir recours le moins possible et
je suis navré de voir l'europe il qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à s'assumer comme
puissance parce que c'est pas du tout
dans son adn en fait l'europe avoir
recours ce genre de procédé qui est
assez facile
assez facile mais auchan contestable du
terme et qu'ils ne règle rien
on est content les six des sanctions
américaines de fonctionner le régime de
castro se serait effondré au bout de six
mois il a duré des décennies des
décennies voyait ce genre de choses en
plein d'exemples où les objectifs n'ont
pas été atteints
mais ce que je dis youtube ultra
minoritaire
oui et hellboy coach sur ce point le
boycott
ça a fonctionné avec l'afrique du sud
par exemple on pense que le boycott
hills a fini par opter par influencer le
pouvoir blanc oui c'est vrai c'est vrai
quand il ya eu à un moment donné il ya
eu une
un accord entre le lisons l'opinion
publique américaine certains dirigeants
américains si athènes grandes
entreprises américaines qui ont dit
c'est quand même plus possible on peut
plus travailler avec le pays si ça bouge
pas et puis ça a été relayé en afrique
du sud par de clerck
de clerck pourrai jamais oublier qu'il a
eu le prix nobel en même temps que
mandela est devenu le prix nobel
ensemble de clerck avait l'intelligence
un moment donné en disant bon il faut
que le pays change en profondeur parce
que sinon donc c'est un bon exemple une
bonne combinaison internes et externes
mais c'est pas simplement des sanctions
aveugle pour écrabouiller un pays on y
est il faut que ça enclencher une
dynamique intelligente d'évolution c'est
qu'elle sait quasiment le cas dans aucun
aucun des exemples de sanctions
américaines que vous pourriez vous citer
ou bien vous êtes le père de
l'expression l'hyperpuissance qui a eu
beaucoup de succès vous parliez des
états unis vous êtes le père d'une autre
expression vous rappelez dans dans ce
livre mais qui a eu beaucoup moins de
succès celi realpolitik et ça personne
ne vous a repris derrière
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler ce
que ses clés realpolitik et pourquoi
c'est un concept qui fonctionne alors il
est de bon ton normalement de critiquer
la realpolitik qui est censé être
horrible cilic immoral et compagnie et
moi il me semble que quand on regarde
l'histoire et les les grands hommes qui
ont fait de la realpolitik
donc c'est vrai de richelieu à de gaulle
qui singer etc
il me semble que souvent en étant très
réalistes ils ont épargné des guerres
trouver des solutions quitte à lutter
contre les opinions extrémistes de leur
époque quand les rois de france pour
desserrer l'étau des habsbourgs autour
s'alliait que des princes protestants
protestants ou même avec le grand turc
s'est déconsidéré comme atroces sur le
plan de nos valeurs les valeurs qui sont
les nôtres c'est elle exprime pas
d'expression mais voyez c'est la même
chose était le parti catholique ultra
qui pensait qu'on pouvait s'allier
qu'avec ceux qui partagent nos valeurs
c'est à dire la monarchie espagnole
c'est à dire des habsbourgs qui étrangle
la france donc il ya eu des dirigeants
souvent richelieu milhas bazar un aussi
petit
on a d'autres où françois 1er à d'autres
moments qui ont pensé autrement celle
c'est de la vraie realpolitik
donc je suis pas d'accord - avec la le
fait de présenter la realpolitik comme
étant quelque chose de totalement
dégoûtant et de scénic
je rappelle d'ailleurs dans le livre que
la vraie définition du cynisme de la
part des philosophes grecs c'est la
capacité à braver l'opinion dominante
c'est pas du tout hein hein amoralisme
répugnons c'est complètement autre chose
bon donc j'ai forgé mais c'est vrai que
ça pas de succès parce qu' il faudrait
qu'ils médias la reprenne il subodore
que c'est une critique contre eux en
fait donc ça c'est moins relayé que
l'hyper puissance dont kiryat le
politique c'est là une politique qui
fondée sur l'irréalisme qui est fondée
sur des chimères une vision fantasmée
peut-être si dialysés marc ducat fontès
et du monde réel en maniement magnan
sans arrêt des concepts comme la
communauté internationale dont on a
parlé qui corresponde pas des réalités
alors qu'il y ait un petit peu de un peu
d'idéalisme très bien peu d'utopie
pourquoi pas un peu de réalisme à la
marge on peut s'en accommoder 1600
englobe tout ça donne une un bain dit
realpolitik et moi j'appelle la halle
les européens qui seraient d'accord et
ce raisonnement essayer d'en sortir
et merci d'avoir donné l'occasion de
dire ça
revenons à la géopolitique évidemment on
sent bien que ce qui a de très important
dans la géopolitique c'est la géographie
c'est bien de lire une carte de regarder
un globe terrestre
c'est la démographie l'a longtemps
gouverné les relations internationales
la démographie évidemment il ya la
puissance technologique et militaire
mais il ya aussi vous assistez beaucoup
là dessus dans votre livre à travers
tous les articles il ya le passé et les
humiliations par exemple qu'on a pu
connaître qu'un peuple a pu connaître et
que ses dirigeants vont réactiver plus
ou moins le passé salaires fondamentale
pour comprendre la géopolitique au fond
l'histoire est aussi importante que la
géographie et oui mais c'est une
évidence c'est bien extraordinaire de
voir rares expliqué sans rien c'est
évident que les peuples fonctionne avec
un
un passé les choses qui leur font peur
plus jamais ça où une une aspiration
on comprend rien la relation entre les
pays de l'est des balkans par exemple si
on n'a pas le passer en tête au moment
de la désintégration de la yougoslavie
tito était assez génial pour faire
coexister tout le monde quand ça s'est
désintégrée dix ans après la mort du
tout temps c'était évident à l'avance
quoi qu'on pense des croates et des
serbes que jamais les creux les croates
des krajina pardon les serbes à ce
qu'ils aimeraient les serbes de krajina
en croatie qui était là depuis aussi
longtemps que les crottes de croatie
accepterait d'être mis sous les ordres
des croates dans lesquelles il voulait
encore les oustachis qui était allié aux
nazis on peut lire cet idiot il ya
longtemps ce pas les mêmes jambes
il n'empêche que c'est est vécu comme ça
et donc si vous prenez les relations
entre les peuples du proche orient les
relations chine japon les relations même
entre les européens même si c'est très
enfouis énormément de situations en
afrique et cetera et cetera où on peut
pas comprendre si on se raccorde pas ça
si on aura quoi passe avec un passé
assez loin plus ou moins lointain dans
les balkans c'est des fois milan avant
vous voyez en chine il faut revenir un
siècle des traités inégaux ou des
dynasties en pleine décadence en chine
n'arrive pas à s'opposer aux stratégies
coloniale des occidentaux des russes et
des japonais etc
donc il faut mettre ça il faut pas
enfermer non plus donc j'ai pensé un
grand danger de couper avec le passé du
passé faisons table rase est toujours
été un slogan effrayant en totalité
absurde et in impraticable en réalité
impraticable il faut pas être non plus
enfermé dedans faut pas voir l'idée que
l'histoire on va vous empêcher de bouger
mais le peut pas parce que l'histoire
vous apprends des choses très
différentes mais elle peut mettre en
garde sur les erreurs principales
données des fils conducteurs des
perspectives bref je suis pour manier
les deux pas marqué les deux héros
historiques et puis la compréhension de
l'actualité
et puis à l'opinion publique est en fait
en vous lisant je me disais mais au fond
les fake news
c'est dans les relations internationales
qu'elles sont le le plus utilisé et ce
alors est-ce que c'est plus grave
aujourd'hui
pour les peuples je sais pas quelque
chose comme la dépêche dems par exemple
qui va être là la cause de la guerre
entre les français et les la prusse
napoléon iii sait très bien que la
dépêche dems est un faux c'est un faux
de bizspark et pourtant il y va il ya un
moment où on a l'impression que les
fakes news c'est plus fort que tout
alors il ya plusieurs choses que oui
bismarck est très malin il réussi à
piéger napoléon iii en utilisant en
misant sur le pignon nationaliste
française unis le pignon humilié excité
qu'il connaît très bien mais ça c'est
une main d'oeuvre classique qui
pouvaient exister même avant les médias
contemporains
après il ya le poids de l'opinion le
poids de l'opinion la plupart des gens
considèrent que c'est un grand progrès
le poids de l'opinion la transparence le
fait de savoir les choses tout de suite
et puis le inspiration une démocratie
directe instantanée par rapport à la
haye la vieille balourde démocratie
représentative
je pense c'est à double tranchant et des
progrès évidemment mais il ya aussi le
fait que ça chauffe les opinions et il
ça rend quand même les compromis très
difficile très difficile alors que dans
les grands les grandes questions envoyez
les questions israélo arabe ou indo
pakistanaise joue entre la chine et le
japon fait plein d'autres sujets un
moment donné ceux qui ont le sens de
l'état le sens de l'avenir qui cherche
le compromis et c'est un moment ils
doivent aller un peu un peu contre les
convictions de leur propre camp un peu
contre les fanatismes interne
c'est-à-dire à ça qu'on reconnaît les
hommes ou les femmes d'état à mon avis
voyez donc si vous avez que des opinions
surexcité et qui veulent commenté à
chaque minute le déroulement d'une
négociation à peu près plus rien des
soluble dans ce monde là d'ailleurs
tocqueville avait perçu c'est un vrai
génie celui-là il est perçu vers les
années 1820 elle uniquement après avoir
passé quelques mois en amérique c'est
quand même incroyable
il avait dit le grand problème à
l'avenir des démocraties c'est qu'elles
vont traiter les questions extérieures
sur la base des considérations
intérieures
ça vous donne des politiques d'opinion
est d'ailleurs le nouveau conseiller
pour la sécurité nationale de joe biden
que je connais pas qui est certainement
très bien il a dit plusieurs fois déjà
la politique et c'est la politique
intérieure c'est la même chose
donc ça veut dire qu'il faut étudier de
près la le poids des opinions par
rapport à des groupes plus ou moins
d'origine ethnique ou bien le poids des
diasporas le poids des lobbys
si ça devient une composante la marge de
manoeuvre des opérateurs des relations
internationales qui devraient montrer
transiger décidé à accepter des
compromis peut-être changer la devenir
de plus en plus compliqué sauf pour les
régimes ultra autoritaire mais il y en
aura de moins en moins ce sera plus
compliqué ce que même dans ses pires
tout un grouillement d'internautes très
mobilisés je me souviens des pourparlers
de paix en irlande sous tony blair à
l'époque c'était à la fin des années 90
j'étais à canal+ à l'époque et j'avais
montré que les gens qui étaient assis
autour de la table chacun avait perdu
des membres de sa famille ou des gens
très proches du fait de celui qui était
en face de lui et c'est très intéressant
de voir qu'au fond c'est avec ses pires
ennemis
on fait toujours la paix et là on était
alors d'ailleurs c'est un peu remis en
cause enfin on peut craindre que ce soit
remis en cause par le bric site
aujourd'hui c'est pour parler de paix
mais mais c'est l'idée qu'on fait la
paix avec avec ses ennemis au fond avec
ceux qui qui vous ont torturé avec ceux
qui ont posé des bombes dans devant la
porte de votre maison qu'on fait la paix
c'est quelque chose qu'on attend ce
peut-être a oublié aujourd'hui mais
peut-être que sont les opinions
publiques qui n'oublie pas les allées
pas les diplomates
c'était le raisonnement de sacs rabin et
arafat à un moment donné il d'ailleurs
rabin a été assassiné par un extrémiste
juif pour cette raison mais c'était le
raisonnement on fait la paix avec ceux
qui vous combattent
donc c'est un c'est un vrai sujet mais
alors vous êtes obligé de rappeler ça
comme étant une remarque de bon sens
c'est une remarque de bon sens mais il
se trouve qu'en occident
après la victoire sur l'ours fait après
la fin de lurçat va dire j'y reviens il
ya eu un vent du bri de triomphalisme
en dix ans on a gagné la démocratie est
ça peut s'imposer partout le marché
aussi cédé récalcitrants on va les
sanctionner ou les bombarder et puis ça
ira
c'est donc à une somme gigantesque
hubris et dans cette époque là notamment
aux états unis mais ça s'est vu un peu
en europe aussi on s'est dit dans ce
contexte n'a plus besoin de politique
étrangère à quoi ça sert d'aller se
compliquer à comprendre l'histoire
l'embrouillé de tous ces peuples qui en
valait tout le monde andy comprenant
s'en fiche tout à son livre est obligé
de suivre et qu'henry kissinger je
reviens encore à lui a été obligé
d'écrire un livre s'était ya une
quinzaine d'années chance pour expliquer
pourquoi les états unis avaient encore
besoin d'une politique étrangère
malgré tout et quand même qu'ils
essayent de comprendre les autres c'est
hallucinant qu'il ait fallu un livre de
ce personnage pour dire ça et les
européens en ont été tentées voir sont
encore tenté par cela même si madame von
der leyen vaillamment dit que la
nouvelle commission et géopolitique elle
a du mérite c'est très bien c'est une
perspective
mais les européens mais souvent ils
continuent à croire que le développement
le marché les normes communes est comme
ça elles suffiront c'est pas vrai il ya
encore une histoire souterraine qui peut
être tout à fait gérer c'est pas
forcément tragique mais qui hélas
l'histoire des peuples qui n'a pas été
dissoute dans la mondialisation dont il
faut là aussi il faut re raccorder le le
passé lointain récent et d'aujourd'hui
et celle d'ailleurs le sujet de votre
livre hubert védrine dictionnaire
amoureux de la géopolitique qui vient de
paraître aux éditions plon faya remercie
d'avoir passé toute cette émission avec
nous merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
je